SCP-682 had escaped containment,
and it was all hands on deck at the SCP
Foundation to try and stop the creature's rampage.
All unarmed personnel were running to escape
before 682 had a chance to rip them apart,
as the security team bravely fought to
incapacitate the hard-to-destroy reptile
long enough to return him to his acid
tank. 682 was on an all-out offensive,
stomping through the SCP's item gallery and
spewing acid at anyone who came within range.
People, items, and parts of the room alike were
melting and sizzling as 682 attacked. It was an
absolute bloodbath, and you'd have to have been
insane to try and fight back against it. However,
one being remained unfazed by the chaos, and
stood proud in the face of the omnicidal monster.
It was another SCP, one who had been broken free
from its glass display case in the commotion.
“Who dares to disturb the Prime Minister
Sinister?” It said, in a high tinny voice.
“I shall rip your eyes from their
sockets and force you to eat them!”
SCP 682 stopped to see who had threatened him. It
was almost laughable that this thing had dared to
make such a violent threat, because there was no
way that this little thing would be able to stand
up to the unkillable 682. But its size didn't
stop it from trying to pick a fight all the same.
The SCP was a tiny robot made from junk,
which looked more like a sculpture made
from scrap that was found on the side
of the road than a functional automaton.
Its head was made of an upside down voltmeter,
giving it the appearance of a smiling face,
and its arms were made of wrenches.
It was capable of walking around,
though it seemed to have difficulty
moving, as it was very top heavy.
It shook its rusty fist at SCP
682 and continued to threaten him,
shouting - "You do not know the fury you have
unleashed! RoboLord the Destructor will end you!"
SCP 682 swiped at the robot, annoyed by
its continued attempts to antagonize him.
The robot toppled over and struggled to stand
again, but when it did, it ran for 682's feet.
It started to grab at 682's toes, hitting them
with its wrench hands. As you might expect,
this had almost no effect on 682.
"You do realize…you
are…weak…pathetic" said 682, raising his claw to
get a better look at the annoying little robot.
It responded- "Lies and slander! The Mayor of
Mayhem is the most powerful being in existence!"
before promptly losing its grip on
682's claw and falling to the floor.
Now 682 was really getting tired of this thing.
He prepared to swipe at it again, this time using
his full strength, which would certainly smash
the robot to pieces. But, luckily for the robot,
its pestering had distracted 682 just long enough
for Foundation security to sneak up on him.
Before 682 had a chance to smash the robot, the
Foundation fired on him with a volley of rockets,
reducing him to a misshapen lump. The
security team collected up 682's remains,
ready to put them into a backup acid tank, but the
task was made slightly more difficult by the fact
that the robot was running around underfoot,
trying in vain to now attack them instead.
What was this strange little robot that thought
it could attack the unkillable lizard, 682? Meet
SCP-1370, appropriately nicknamed “The Pesterbot”
by Foundation personnel. Pesterbot is a small
robot made of junk that displays sentience and the
ability to move despite having no power source.
Everything about SCP-1370 defies common sense.
The voltmeter that serves as
its head contains no sensors,
but it seems unable to see if the voltmeter is
covered. Its arms and legs are made of wrenches
and its wooden torso contains a speaker which it
communicates through in a tinny, monotone voice.
Pesterbot lives in SCP Gallery 27, in a glass
display case which is 125 cm tall, 50 cm wide,
and 75 cm long. Level 2 personnel and higher are
allowed to remove the robot from containment at
their discretion, but penalties will be incurred
for anyone who doesn't return to its case.
Due to its impractical, top-heavy design,
Pesterbot falls over frequently when it walks
around. This led the foundation to believe that
he was created as an art project and was later
somehow imbued with anomalous properties, rather
than being made with the intent of being sentient.
Pesterbot has demonstrated a high capacity
for learning, having been taught how to speak
in English, French, and Latin. However,
the major factor hampering attempts to
further test its intelligence has nothing
to do with its robotic processing power.
No, it’s because of its poor attitude.
Pesterbot's encounter with SCP-682 and
the cockiness it expressed in the moment
wasn’t an aberration, this SCP really believes
it's a killing machine, and as a result,
it will pick a fight with anyone and anything that
moves. This even includes its own reflection - and
as a result the glass of its container must
be made as non-reflective as possible to
prevent the robot from damaging the case or
itself in attempts to fight its mirror self.
Though its most commonly used nickname in the
Foundation is Pesterbot, SCP-1370 also goes by
a variety of self-given epithets, including
Doom Bot 2000, Robolord the Destructor, and
Darth Claw Killflex. It can be made to add new
names to this list through encouragement by staff,
and over time they have managed
to add the name Pesterbot,
as well as the even more ridiculous “Patheticon
the Garglemost”, to its lexicon of names.
As you may have surmised, Pesterbot is
classified as Safe and is treated by most
SCP foundation employees as a humorous
oddity rather than a legitimate threat.
Many tests have been done on Pesterbot, and
they've all conclusively determined that the
robot is incapable of inflicting
any damage to its opponents.
In fact, Pesterbot is more of a danger
to itself than to anything around it.
Both because it's incredibly clumsy and awkward,
and because it frequently picks fights with
other SCPs who are far more powerful than it.
One such scenario that could've gone
far worse for Pesterbot than it did
was its encounter with SCP-846,
also known as Robo-Dude,
one of the many Dr. Wondertainment products
currently kept in Foundation containment.
Robo-Dude is an ordinary-looking toy robot
that, upon request, can produce up to 350
“robo-accessories” that function as real weapons.
Robo-Dude can deploy everything from a rocket
launcher to a flamethrower to a gun
that shoots out an unknown species
of insect that can chew through wood. However,
Robo-Dude seems to not be sentient, and is
unable to use these weapons unless asked to. That
ultimately worked out in the favor of Pesterbot.
During another SCP-682 escape, the two robots were
brought into contact as they both had been broken
out of their respective containment spaces during
the brouhaha. Robo-Dude, searching for a Robo-Pal
to play with, came upon Pesterbot, who immediately
started spouting its usual overdramatic threats.
“I am the Crushmaster, doom to all I survey.”
Pesterbot said. “Gaze upon my might and weep.
Identify yourself, that I might
know whose destruction I shall sow.”
Robo-Dude, not programmed to know
how to respond to such a statement,
simply responded by asking
Pesterbot if it wanted to play.
Pesterbot continued to trash-talk
Robo-Dude, until Robo-Dude decided
the best way to play with its new pal
was to engage in its Robo-Dance mode.
Pesterbot accepted the challenge, saying “Activate
all that you wish, but your fate is sealed. The
Kill-o-tron can not be defeated. I shall render
you unto dust with my mad dancing skills."
The two robots proceeded to engage in
a dance battle, which the awkwardly
shaped Pesterbot failed miserably at.
While Robo-Dude was a competent dancer,
Pesterbot could only gyrate pathetically, before
it fell over and rolled around on the ground,
hopelessly out of time to the music
coming from Robo-Dude's speakers.
The song ended, and Robo-Dude declared
- “Robo-dance is complete, Robo-pal.”
Pesterbot was unable to accept its
failure, and replied- "Ha. Pathetic one,
you have been schooled in the art of the
dance by none other than Mechanobasher,
Scourge of a Thousand Worlds. Kneel before
me before I end your worthless existence."
Robo-Dude, unimpressed with Pesterbot's poor
sportsmanship, deployed its hydrogen cannon,
which it was programmed to do whenever
it detected a sore loser. Fortunately
for Pesterbot, ”hydrogen cannon” was just
the name for Robo-Dude's water pistol.
While Pesterbot will attempt to fight anything
that moves, the truth is, this robot will attack
virtually anything it perceives as being
even slightly alive. This is perhaps best
illustrated by one of the tests of Pesterbot's
abilities that involved putting a small speaker
at the base of a potted houseplant and
speaking through it from another room.
The plant was placed across from
Pesterbot in the testing chamber
and the interaction was monitored by
researchers from outside. Researcher
Davies spoke through the speaker in the plant
pot. He asked Pesterbot if it could hear him,
and it answered - “Who dares. All souls
will burn. You will feel the sharp sting
of my wrath. Identify yourself so that I
may sing damnation upon you as you die.”
The robot began approaching the plant. Davies,
speaking as the plant, identified himself,
“I am a split-leaf philodendron, a
semi-woody shrub with large glossy leaves.”
At this point, he had to try very hard not
to laugh at the absurdity of this test,
and the robot's reaction.
He continued “These leaves can
grow up to three feet long.”
Pesterbot used its wrench arms to
try and wrestle with the leaves,
but was bested by the mighty plant and unable
to cause any damage. Enraged by its failure,
it said “Your mockery spells your doom. I have
arrived. You will be crushed betwixt my digits.”
Pesterbot then fell over and
was unable to right itself.
It struggled and spent 6 minutes trying to stand
before its flailing knocked over the plant,
which did nothing to help and in fact pinned
the robot to the ground. It was at this point
that the researchers, who had taken time to
compose themselves after several laughing fits,
entered the chamber and removed Pesterbot in
order to place it back in its containment case.
Despite how non-threatening Pesterbot
is, there is actually one situation
in the Foundation's history where it has
actually posed a somewhat serious threat.
When Mobile Task Forces were sent in to
rescue survivors of the events at Site-13,
also known as SCP-1730, they were
attacked by alternate universe
versions of a variety of creatures
kept in Foundation containment.
One of these creatures was Pesterbot, who had
in that universe somehow gained control of a
larger mechanical body constructed
of discarded pieces of machinery.
It threw other pieces of metal scrap at the task
force members as they tried to leave the site,
shouting in a much deeper and more intimidating
voice - “I am reborn to breathe devastation
upon this fetid Earth. Pitiful humans. You will
feel the dark sting of my neverending torment.”
Members of the task force could see
the original Pesterbot body on top of
the larger metal construct, waving its arms madly.
The task force opened fire, to little effect.
Pesterbot tossed another piece of
scrap at them, just narrowly missing.
One task force member threw a frag grenade at
the robot, which it caught, blowing up its hand.
Another one was able to jump into the air and
reach the tiny robot atop the larger body,
knocking it against the wall and shattering it.
Even in the reality where Pesterbot
was able to build itself a larger body,
it still ultimately wasn't able
to put up that much of a fight.
Poor Pesterbot. Doomed to be a failure in
this, and apparently, every other reality.
That's the story of SCP 1370, also known as the
Pesterbot, one of the most hilariously harmless
anomalous entities that the foundation currently
has in containment. Perhaps one day he’ll achieve
his goal of conquering the universe, he just has
to figure out how to conquer his toy box first.
Now check out “SCP-001 - The Scarlet King”
and “SCP-999 - The Tickle Monster” for more
fascinating beings from the SCP Foundation!